the way you think about your current
work I think applies in great journalism
in in politics as well so what happens I
I have that sense
because I aspire to be like you in the
in the sort of in the conversation space
of like uh with politicians I try to
talk to people on the left and the right
and do so in a nonpartisan way and
criticize but also steal men in their
cases what happens I've learned is when
you talk to somebody on the right
the right kind of brings you in it's
like yes we'll keep you comfortable come
with us and then the left attacks you
and and so uh and the same happens on
the left you talking on the left the
right attacks you yeah and the left as
they come with us so like there's a
there's a Temptation and uh a momentum
to staying to that one side whatever
that side is
um the same with foreign journalism you
can cover Putin critically there's a
strong pull to being pro Ukraine pro
zolenski pro
basically really covering in a favorable
way to the point of propaganda to the
point of PR the zelenski regime if you
criticize the landscare regime there's a
strong pull towards then being
supportive of not necessarily the Putin
regime but a very different perspective
on it which is like NATO is the one that
created that war there's a there's a
there's narratives that pull you and
what I think a great journalist does is
make enemies and plus size
and walk through that fire and not get
pulled in to the protection of anyone's
side because it gets so harshly attacked
anytime they deviate from the center
well and I think also like
there's a criticism of all centrists
which I think in some way is fair and I
say that to someone largely who's this
interest which is that this what about
is or like this like what about the left
or what about the right can skew when
it's not a one it's not a both sides
issue
so in the case of like Russia Ukraine I
think like I'm strongly in favor of
Ukraine even though I tend to go like on
both sides and that might be partly
because one of my employees is Ukrainian
um and I think
what a great journalist does especially
like in politics is I think they
criticize
the regime that's most in Power most
controls the keys and is the most
corrupt at that time and they might
appear to be like let's say during the
realm of trump
a great journalist would criticize Trump
but that same journalist who held
Trump's feet to the fire should be
capable of holding Biden's feet to the
fire four years later if that kind of
makes sense that's exactly right yeah
yeah so any uh revealing any so
attacking any power center for the
corruption for the flaws they have uh
the perspective of like your political
agenda or your political ideas
yeah so that and that's what I mean
about sort of the war in Ukraine there
are several key players NATO
Russia Ukraine China uh
India
I mean there's several less uh important
players maybe some of the like Iran and
like Israel and maybe Africa
and what great journalism take requires
is basically revealing the flaws of each
one of those players irrespective of the
attacks you get and you're right that
throughout any particular situation
there is some some parties that are
worse than others and you have to
um weigh your perspective accordingly
but also it requires you to be Fearless
in certain things like for example I
don't even know
what it's like to be a journalist
covering China now
oh that's an exact case of like China
has made it so difficult to be a good
journalist that they've effectively
squashed criticism because to be a
journalist in China means constantly
risking your life every single day to
criticize that government and so the
best journalists are a lot of times
outside the country
um or they have sources inside the
country who are like there's like this
you know
different there's layers to the
journalism where there's insiders who
are leaking information but they
themselves cannot publish because it's
like it's you know it's it's extremely
risky so
yeah I think I think as a society one
measure of how healthy the political
structure is is how well you can
criticize it without fearing for your
safety
in that sense the chaos and the
bickering going on in the United States
politics is a good thing that people can
criticize very harshly very harsh and be
in terms of safety are pretty safe yes
absolutely I think our only challenge is
like where it gets dangerous is around
like top secret information the
government comes down so hard that
the danger in in covering politics here
is you can expose something that's top
secret that should be exposed and
they'll ruin you so that's where you
again give props to Snowden for stepping
up 100 100 percent